We in the last video we took
the Macloren series of
representation of e to the x.
Now let's do it with a couple
of other functions and we'll
see in a few videos it all fits
together like a giant puzzle.
Let's do cosine of x.
Let's set f of x, f of x
is equal to cosine of x.
What's f prime of x?
What's the first derivative
of cosine of x?
Well that just equals
minus sine of x.
Minus sine of x.
What's the second derivative?
Well that's just minus times
derivative of sine of x.
So the derivative of sine
of x is cosine x, it's
minus cosine of x.
And what's the
third derivative?
f 3 of x.
The derivative of cosine x is
minus sine of x, we already
have a minus here so it
becomes positive sine of x.
What's f 4 of x?
The fourth derivative of x?
It equals cosine of x again.
As we keep taking derivatives
we'll keep repeating and the
pattern will go on, right?
The fifth derivative of x, the
fifth derivative of this
function, the fourth is the
same as a function, so the
fifth is going to be the same
as the first derivative.
cosine of x is sine of x.
Hopefully you see the pattern.
We're going to do the Macloren
representation, which is a
specific example of the Taylor
series where we figure out the
values of the derivatives
at x is equal to zero.
So let's do that right now.
So f of zero, let me do
it in to another color
to fend off monotony.
f of zero.
What's cosine of zero?
Cosine of zero is 1.
f prime of zero is equal to
sine of-- well not minus sine
of zero, but what sine of zero?
Sine of zero is zero,
so minus zero is still
zero, so this is zero.
f prime prime of zero.
Cosine of zero we
already know is one.
We have a negative sine here,
so it becomes a minus one.
The third derivative at
x is equal to zero.
Sine of zero is zero.
So this is zero.
I think you might start to
see a pattern emerging.
The fourth derivative at zero.
Cosine of zero is equal to 1.
And then the fifth derivative,
this is hard to read but you
get the point is
just zero again.
So what's the pattern as
we take the derivatives?
1, zero, minus 1,
zero, 1, zero.
So it alternates
between zero and 1.
So 1, zero, minus 1, zero,
positive, zero, negative,
zero, positive.
So every other number is zero
and in between them we
alternate between a positive
1 and a negative 1.
So now let's use that
information to figure
out them the Macloren
series representation.
So we proved, hopefully, we
didn't prove it definitely
converges over the entire
domain of the function.
You have to take
my word for it.
We'll experiment a little bit
with a graphing calculator
in a few videos.
We said that this
representation-- and it should
make intuitive sense, because
when you take the infinite
Macloren series, when you take
that infinite sum, you're
essentially creating a function
where that function is equal to
your original function at
the point you chose.
In the case of a Macloren we're
picking x equals zero, and it
equals every derivative
of this function.
Just intuitively it seems, well
if a function equals something
at a point and every one of its
derivatives is also equal to
the function at that point,
maybe those functions are
equal to each other.
I haven't proven
that to you yet.
We know that the representation
is a sum from n is equal to
zero to infinity of the nth
derivative evaluated at zero.
A Macloren series is a specific
case of a Taylor series.
We actually haven't done
anything with Taylor series, I
was hoping to get there later.
But the Macloren series is a
really cool one because it's
going to show us all these
relationships between e and
cosine and sine and eventually
i and pi and you will
find it exciting.
The Macloren is that times x
to the n over n factorial.
That's what we said it was.
So if this is our f of x, f
of x is cosine of x, what
does this turn into?
Well, f of x is equal to, it
equals f of zero times x to
the zero over zero factorial,
that's just one, right?
Plus, now we're at n equals 1.
It's the first
derivative at zero.
f prime of zero, well
that's just equal to zero.
And who cares what that--
that would be x to the
first over 1, right?
Now we're at the
second derivative.
The second derivative
at zero is minus 1.
Minus 1 times x squared
over 2 factorial plus the
third derivative at zero.
The third derivative at zero
we figured out was zero.
Zero who cares what that is.
It would have been x to the
third over 3 factorial.
And then what's the
fourth derivative?
The fourth derivative at
zero is just equal to 1.
So we have times 1 and then
we're at x to the fourth
over 4 factorial.
Let me see if I can write
this a little bit neater.
The next one, the fifth
derivative at zero times x to
the fifth over 5 factorial.
We'll keep going.
Let me write this, clean this
up and hopefully the pattern
merges if it hasn't
emerged already.
f of x is equal to cosine of x
is equal to-- let met get rid
of the zeros-- 1 and then we
have minus x squared
over 2 factorial.
This term, this goes away.
This is a zero term.
And the next one is a positive.
Plus x to the fourth
over 4 factorial.
And the fifth term goes away.
But then the cycle continues.
The next one is
going to be minus.
Because we had minus 1 plus 1.
It's going to be minus x to
the sixth over 6 factorial.
You could take the
sixth derivative.
You'll see that the derivative
of minus sine of x is minus
cosine of x, that's where
we get the minus 1 from.
And they we're
going to go plus.
So we're just taking all the
even terms. x to the eighth
over 8 factorial minus x to
the 10th over 10 factorial.
We could just keep going
on and on and on.
And so we have a situation
where we can rewrite cosine of
x is equal to the sum, if you
believe that this Macloren
series actually does converge
to cosine of x over the entire
domain of x, that's kind of
an assumption we're making.
Hopefully one day we will have
the tools set to actually
prove that as well.
From n is equal to zero.
So what's happening?
We're taking all of
the even powers.
So we could say x to the 2n,
that ensures that no matter
what value of n I put in
here I get an even numbers.
So we'll go to the zeroth
power then the second
power, over 2n factorial.
So that takes care of going
from 1 to x squared over 2,
to x to the fourth over
4 factorial, 6 over 6
factorial, et cetera.
But now we have to make it
switched signs like that.
Well let's just multiply
it negative 1.
Let's see what we can do.
Negative 1 to the-- so we want
the first term to be positive,
the second term to be negative.
So we could say times
minus 1 to the n plus 1.
Let's see if that works.
When m is zero what's
negative 1 to the n plus 1?
zero, it would be minus 1.
And then when it's 1-- When
it's zero-- no, no it's just
going to be negative
1 to the n.
Because when it's zero,
negative 1 to zero is 1.
When it's 1, negative 1.
So this will work out.
Negative 1 to the n is cosine.
You could try it out.
This is the n is equal to zero.
We need to switch colors.
That's n is equal to zero and
here we get x to the zero over
zero factorial, which is 1.
We have negative 1 to the zero
is 1, so that becomes 1.
When n is equal to 1, this
becomes x squared over 2
factorial, we have negative 1
to the 1 power, so that's
where you get the negative 1.
And then when n is equal to
2, the negative 1 squared
becomes positive again.
So the negative 1 is
what provides the
alternating numbers.
So pretty neat.
We just figured out another
way to represent cosine of x.
And it might be looking a
little bit interesting to you
that this representation kind
of resembles part of the
representation of e to the x.
What's the difference between
this and the e to the x? e to
the x had the odd exponent
terms and it didn't
switch signs.
But other than that, they're
pretty much the same.
So in the next video we'll
do sine of x and then we'll
try to put it all together.
I'll see you soon.